this is unreal what an insane twist as
Gojo is declared the winner of the
biggest fight in the history of Jujutsu
Kaizen Shinjuku is destroyed and sukuna
definitely isn't beating the fraud kuna
allegations Gage was cooking Gojo was
cooking and we need to talk about this
right now you guys know how this works
if you enjoy our Jujutsu Kaizen videos
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment right now
for that YouTube algorithm and if you
want to help us get this channel to
special grade status by hitting 2
million subscribers do me a favor and
subscribe right now we are getting
closer to that insane 2 million numbers
so every subscription counts finally
this video will of course contain
Jujutsu Kaizen manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned just a little while ago things
weren't looking so great for Gojo as
sukunai used mahuraga and agito 2-3v1
him Gojo even lost his arm during the
course of the last chapter you strongly
considered intervening in the fight to
help Gojo and to make it at least a fair
fight but he was ultimately advised
against intervening by kusakabem and the
others having his students there on the
battlefield might make things even
harder on Gojo as he would then feel
responsible for keeping them all safe on
top of trying to take care of himself in
addition sukuna likely has a trump card
that he is planning to use when the
others intervene so they shouldn't
intervene unless Gojo is weakened to
such an extent that intervention becomes
the only option but even though things
seemed bad there was a huge twist at the
end of the last chapter Gojo used blue
at maximum output to destroy agito he
also began growing back his right hand
despite speculation that he may not be
able to heal himself anymore and the
narrator told us that within 41 seconds
Gojo will successfully use hollow
technique purple to leveled the playing
field like literally the latest chapter
begins in the immediate aftermath of
agito's Destruction as sukunai and
mahora got real from the shock of what
just happened after all they themselves
just barely avoided being caught up in
Gojo's attack Gojo quickly regrows his
right arm fully and once again he has a
smile on his face the narrator describes
this as satoru Gojo's voltage Rising
even further and I honestly wish that we
could have seen shoko's face in the
exact moment that Gojo healed his arm so
easily while smiling she was
legitimately so worried about him and
she thought that he may no longer be
able to heal himself because of how far
he has been pushing himself so I can
just picture everyone in that viewing
room turning to look at shoko right
after it happened clearly she
underestimated our boy the narrator then
makes it clear that the king of curses
ryomen sukuna is feeling nervous for the
first time in a thousand years and yeah
yes it's one thing to look at sukuna's
expression and speculate that he might
be getting worried about Gojo but it's
quite another thing to have the narrator
straight up confirm that sukuna is
nervous he will never beat those fraud
kuna allegations now the dude was caught
in 4k by the narrator himself
but obviously sukunai isn't like giving
up or anything and he and mahuraga
engage Gojo in close range hand-to-hand
combat once again it's a 2V1 but at
least it's better than the 3v1 we saw in
the previous chapter Gojo's martial arts
skills appear to be on a higher level
than sukunas because in the middle of
this 2V1 Gojo manages to grab sukuna's
arm and throw the king of curses right
into maharaga he then follows up with a
deadly black flash punch that tsukuna
manages to avoid just barely because
mahuraga blocks it with his own body
this is like the fourth black flash that
Gojo landed by the way so this is just
incredible Gojo then deliberately backs
away from his two opponents in order to
give himself some space he proceeds with
preparations for yet another big
finishing move sukuna senses the start
of Gojo's cursed energy as it begins to
flow out in preparation for a major
curse technique maneuver the narrator
explains that just like the sure hit
effect that happens right before the
main expansion there is always a
specific starting point for a big move
even though Gojo has incredibly
efficient cursed energy consumption
thanks to the six eyes he is not an
exception in this regard due to the type
and amount of cursed energy involved
sukuna senses that Gojo is about to use
cursed technique reversal red and he
prepares to have maharaga take the force
of the hit and adapt to Red in the
process although sukuna's judgment
wasn't wrong it was incomplete in short
sukuna doesn't realize that Gojo is
cooking Hollow technique purple is of
course a combination of red and blue the
two opposite forces clash and create
purple a force that annihilates
everything in sight it seems that the
blue that Gojo had used earlier to
destroy agito still remained active
after agito's demise and sukuna quickly
realizes that he needs to destroy either
blue or red in order to prevent them
from clashing with each other and
creating purple mahuraga begins pursuing
blue in order to destroy it before it
makes contact with red but Gojo is able
to boost his speed by piggybacking on
the effects of blue and he then punches
maguraga out of the way however sukuna
is now there as well and he tries to
destroy red with a piercing blood attack
in an attempt to make it explode before
it reaches blue Gojo quickly attacks
sukuna but not before sukuna manages to
fire off his attack directly at Red
tsukuna believes that he succeeded and
that Gojo was too late but Gojo just
looks at tsukuna and moves his technique
to the next phase kojo chance and this
appears to strengthen blue and its
effect and so instead of hitting red
sukuna's attack is attracted to and
absorbed into blue we see Utah
apologizing to kusakabe for even
considering to interfere before because
if he had been there he would have
hindered Gojo's concentration and what
he just did would have been impossible
and what Gojo just did was successfully
merge red and blue to activate Hollow
technique purple mahuraga and sukuna
look absolutely shook as Gojo smiles and
utters the word purple and then a
massive explosion literally flattens a
huge chunk of Shinjuku makuraga is
destroyed completely and while Gojo and
sukuna are both injured sukuna's
injuries are clearly more severe and
tsukuna is barely standing his left hand
is missing and he is an absolute bloody
wreck Gojo then points out this exact
thing he was forced to use purple
without aiming it which means that he
also got caught up in the explosion
however it is clear that the damage
sukuna sustained is a lot more severe
Gojo believes that because it was his
own cursed energy that created the
attack he was not harmed as badly as his
opponent sukuna is now alone the
shikigami are gone he is seriously
injured his healing is slow and he
doesn't have a fist to use for domain
amplification as Yuji and the others
look on kusakabe proclaims that Gojo is
the winner Gojo wins suguna loses the
greatest battle in the history of JuJu
Kaizen is finally over
or is it it's important to remember that
it was not the narrator who proclaimed
Gojo to be the winner it was kusakabe
and that means we can't count sukuna out
just yet
sukuna still has that trump card that
was brought up so prominently in the
previous chapter and sukunao also still
has megumi which he can potentially use
as leverage I mean sure Gojo wants
sukuna to believe that he is prepared to
sacrifice megumi for victory but that
may not really be the case when it
really comes down to it Gojo May
hesitate to kill megumi and that could
give sukuna some kind of Advantage
nevertheless after everything we've
witnessed so far and after the narrator
confirmed that tsukuna is nervous
because he knows that Gojo could win
this a good argument can be made for
Gojo being the stronger sorcerer all
things being even you could definitely
argue that Gojo would ultimately defeat
sukuna in a fair one-on-one however as I
said sukuna still has leverage with
megumi he has that trump card which may
or may not be something sneaky and
there's always kenjaku who might be
planning to help sukuna at just the
right moment despite the fact that Gojo
was declared the winner my opinion is
that this fight isn't over yet
tsukuna might have been bested by Gojo
but that doesn't mean that this is a
fair fight or that this fight is over
sukuna will either use his trump card or
he will use megumi in some way or
kenjaku or something along those lines
in order to stay in the fight he might
also use some trick to escape from the
fight so that he can live to fight
another day but I definitely don't think
that Gojo will just get a clean W here
and literally kill sukuna the Jujutsu
Kaizen story might be entering its
climax but it's not over yet and we
still haven't seen the last of sukuna
after all we still haven't seen sukuna
enter his forearm form from a thousand
years ago we still haven't seen Yuji
reach his full potential we still
haven't seen what exactly Kendrick was
going to do with Tangen so the story
must continue even if this particular
fight were to end soon that would not be
the end of the story what do you guys
think is fraud kuna done for or does he
still have a trump card is the fight
going to end soon or do we still have a
lot of chat of this fight ahead of us
and even if the fight were to end soon
what would that mean for the rest of the
story what is the next Arc don't forget
to let me know your thoughts down in the
comments below if you're looking for an
epic jiu Jutsu Kaizen video to watch
next don't miss our video that explains
and ranks every special grade sorcerer
introduced to Kaizen link on screen and
in the description if you enjoyed this
jjk video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like to let me
know and if you want to help this
channel attain special grade status by
hitting 2 million subscribers subscribe
right now